everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
looking at game 15 from the 1972 World
Chess Championship between Bobby Fischer
and Betty Spassky and Bobby Fischer
coming in to round 15 has a three-point
advantage so things are looking up for
him he does have the black pieces in a
game 15 but he's fast keep looking to
get something going with the white
pieces so we're going to get started
starts out with pawn to e4 and then pawn
to c5 this is the Sicilian offense from
Bobby Fischer Knight to f3 upon to a d6
upon a d4 pawn captures Knight to d4
Knight here to f6 Knight c3 and then
pawn to a6 so this is getting into the
knight Dorf defense a very common
especially from Bobby Fischer Bishop to
g5 so continuing in the mainline pawn to
e6 pawn to f4 and then Bishop to e7 now
we did see Bobby Fischer in game 11 play
Queen down here to b6 going for the
poisoned pawn variation this is Bobby
Fischer's favorite variation in the
night door for the fence that he had
never lost ever in a competitive match
before game number 11 when he played
this he ended up taking the pawn on b2
but his basket was able to trap the
Queen take the Queen and end up winning
that game so I'm not sure if Bobby
Fischer was just a little gun-shy after
losing that just a few games ago but at
the end the day decided to go against
his favorite line in the night Dorf
defense and instead just play the main
line of Bishop here to e7 play continues
with Queen to f3 the main line and then
Queen to c7 and nowadays Queen to c7
sometimes as pawn to age six but the
main line in this day and age was for
the Queen to come here to c7 now we see
buddy Spassky Castle on the Queen side
of the board Knight here to d7 Bishop to
d3 and there's really two lines that
you'll see Bishop to d3 is one of them
another would be pawn to g4 anytime you
castle on one side
the board usually gonna be pushing your
pawns to the other side because that's
generally where you're gonna be seeing
your opponent castle especially since
Bobby Fischer does not have a lot of
protection on the queenside castling on
the kingside does look like it it's
going to be the most common line for
Bobby Fischer and these would be two of
the most you know theoretical openings
that you'll see from whites perspective
and the night door if the fence is
Bishop here to d3 and pawn to d4 just
been studied for so long
many many chess experts have a lot of
opinions on how you can continue has
just been played in so many games but we
see buddy Spassky played Bishop to d3
pawn to b5 so really pushing onto the
Queen side of the board rook to e1
centralizing and then Bishop to b7 Bobby
Fischer does have to be careful about
pushing up too far a pawn to b4 gets
into trouble because of a knight here to
d5 now if you look at and say well
couldn't just the the pawn take here
well yes he could but after now the
knight comes to f5 things get pretty
tricky as far as how black is going to
continue from here the knight is
attacking both the pawn here on at g7 as
well as the bishop here on e7 after the
knight takes the King would have to
recapture but if black were to play
something like rook to g8 then things
get even more difficult pawn takes on d5
now the rook is pinning down the bishop
here on e7 to the King then I can take
it is also being protected by the rooks
oh it's just really really bad form from
blacks perspective if he decides to try
to push further with pawn to b4 somebody
because the knight can just come up here
to d5 does it look like that's a actual
good move but it ends up being very very
strong for white so instead Bobby
Fischer correctly plays Bishop here to
b7 this does pin down this pawn here on
e4 to the Queen so the pawn just can't
push forward here to e5 which is what
white would like to do so instead we see
the bishop come here to b7 and then the
Queen coming over here to g3 this does
get the Queen
out of the pin it also opens up the door
for an attack on g7
once there is an exchange here on f6 now
without already knowing what would
happen in this game you look at this
position you would expect a lot of high
level players to play something like
Knight to h5 this protects the square
here on g7 which could fall after
there's an exchange in the Queen is
attacking it as well as it just attacks
this Queen right here so it really puts
white to the test but that's not how
Bobby Fischer plays he's not always
looking for the material advantage in a
game or even material equilibrium he's
looking for the best attack that he can
find and so he says yeah I'm gonna go
ahead and castle on the Queen side
doesn't necessarily look at the fact and
say I have great protection that's not
what he's looking for and so that's what
he does he castles on the Queen side
Bishop takes on f6 the knight recaptures
here on f6 and then the Queen takes on
g7 so Bobby Fischer not only castles to
a cyber it doesn't have a lot of
protection but it gives up a pawn so
that he can start in attack e plays rook
here to f8 wants to protect this pawn
right here and he's gonna start to
attack on the Queen side where he does
have his own King so Queen comes back
here to g3 pawn to b4 he now finds it
safe to start pushing with his pawns
so pawn to b4 Knight here to a4 and then
rook to g8 forcing the Queen to move
Queen comes back here to f2 Knight to d7
trying to just move it over to the Queen
side of the board King to be one King
here to b8 as well just wants to make
sure you know from blacks perspective
that it's not pinned down to the Queen
and then this King as well wants to make
sure it's just a safer Square now I can
start to push this pawn as well being on
the same file as this Queen is just
dangerous pawn says to c3 and this is
where things get interesting from white
he has a few options as far as how buddy
Spassky wants to continue pawn to c4 I
think is a nice move you know if the
pawn wants to take here with on passant
that's fine a knight can come back here
and take
so that's going to be fine yes that is a
legal move for anyone that's watching it
curious how that happens on passant is
the move another option would be Queen
to e2 centralizing this does allow for
the bishop to come up here and attack so
just another threat you know for the
Queen to get involved so all these are
are good options now these are
definitely gonna be better than
something like pawn to e5 if you want to
attack in this area of the board because
the bishop and the rook are both eyeing
down the square here on g2 so rook comes
down here to g2 forcing the Queen to
move this is not gonna be good for white
but instead decides to play pawn to c3
which I think gives Bobby Fischer some
more attacking options the night plays
to a c5 and then the bishop comes back
here to see - we do see the exchange
after Knight takes on c3 a bishop here
to f6 now we do see buddy Spassky with a
very solid setup here especially after
pawn to g3 solidified his pawn chain he
is up in material so all things
considered White has a very good board
presence Bobby Fischer it doesn't have a
lot of king protection in front of that
he does have a bishop here that's the
main thing that's going well for Bobby
Fischer I think they though he has a lot
of material Bobby Fischer being a very
aggressive player knows what to do with
a ton of material so it's gonna be an
exciting end of the game Bobby Fischer
continues with pawn to h5 now we see
pawn to e5 trying to break up the center
of the board now the pawn takes here on
e5 pawn recaptures and now white does
have an isolated pawn in the center of
the board the Bobby Fischer can start to
attack Fischer comes back here to h8
still putting pressure on here but wants
to make sure it does retreat now Knight
comes back here to f3 this does defend
the square here on e5 also opens up the
door for this rook on a d1 to control
this long open file rook here to d8
says yeah I'll go ahead and exchange
that don't want you to have control the
D file Bobby Fischer retakes here on d8
and now the knight comes up here to g5
so an interesting
approach of you know how white wants to
continue doesn't have to come up here
this does open up the door for the
bishop to come down and take here on e5
which is what Bobby Fischer does now the
Queen comes up and takes on f7 so
getting some of that material back but
definitely a huge turn of events as far
as how white wanted to continue he gave
up that center pawn in exchange for the
Queen coming up here to f7 and said yeah
if you want exchange that's completely
fine still up a pawn of material Bobby
Fischer not looking to do that
recognizing that you know when you are
down a pawn in material you don't want
to exchange down you want to have your
most important pieces still on the board
so you could have a strong attack that's
exactly what he continues to do
especially with the bishop pair he needs
to be aggressive the Queen come back
here to h5 and this is probably where
white gets a little greedy the Queen
coming here to h5 does limit the Queen
involved in the action playing something
like Queen to f1 still keeps it involved
into the game you know from here we
could see the Bishop take here on c3
pawn take here on c3 maybe the rook
comes down here to d5 just imagine that
the Queen there on f1 and you'll see the
difference and what actually happened
the Queen came to h5 in the game Bobby
Fischer took on a c3 after the pond
recaptured on c3 then Queen to b6 check
now there's a couple options that Bernie
Spassky has here they're really King
here to a-1 or King here to see one King
to a1 it is probably the better move
we're now gonna see Queen to a5
attacking the pawn here on c3 and
there's not a lot of great ways for
white to the fin that's really the only
good way is the queen up here to h8 this
is check and now the thinning the square
so keen to a seven and then rook over
here to b1 this does stop a lot of
threats per does protect the King here
on a once this is probably how it would
continue if white chose that the King
here
to a one did not instead decided to play
King here to see one which just gets it
in the center of the board just keeps it
at more exposed and I think what each
basket wanted to now the Queen comes to
a five Czech Queen up to eight eight so
that's gonna be the same here King to a
seven pawn up here to a four and then we
see the night come down here to d3 NSE
but it but he's Spassky you know was a
little lucky here we see Bobby Fischer
had the option of the night taking on a
four and then the Bishop takes Queen
takes here on a four maybe the Queen
comes down here to e5 but black can put
a lot of pressure on his opponent
especially with the Queen here on a8
thinking getting is rook involved at any
time he can surprise his opponent with
this LightSquared Bishop so I think this
is a better option for Bobby Fischer but
in the game this had to play Knight here
to d3 Bishop takes rook comes down here
and takes here on d3 and then King up
here to see two attacking the rook rook
comes back here to d5 attacking the
knight and then we see rook here to e4
now if you look at this and say okay
well the rook and the Queen are both
attacking the knight why does the rook
come up here to e4 why not just take
this pawn right here well the knight
takes on e6 and this is going to be a
mating opportunity for Bobby Fischer
queen takes on a four check can't come
over to the D file since the rook is
defending that so let's just say queen
or king comes to be one Queen down to b3
just moving it around Queen to a3 King
down to a b1 and now rook to d1 after
the King comes up here because if the
rook captures then Bishop down here to
e4 the rook is forced to come up here to
a d3 and then it's going to be checkmate
so instead you know maybe the King comes
to c2 trying to prolong things King up
here her queen up here to a4 check also
protecting the rook here King to b2 and
then rook
- King down here to be one and then it
is going to be a checkmate very very
quickly so things would be bad if that
Knight decided to come up and take their
on e6 now if we come back and say okay
well instead that the rook came here to
e4 now the work comes back to d8 why
does Bobby Fischer not take the night
here on g5 he absolutely could that is
one of the options that he was looking
at if the rook takes here on g5 then the
Queen's gonna come down to d4 check then
you know really need to have some sort
of protection so Queen here - a c5 rook
to e6 you know B it'd be great if there
was an exchange but that's not what
White's looking to do here since black
is that material so first takes the pawn
up here now the Queen takes pawn takes
here and it's just interesting both
sides are equal and material Bobby
Fischer does have the minor piece and
the bishop but he's just gonna have to
worry about so many ponds that's not the
way Bobby Fischer wants to play this
game he can't really be as aggressive as
he wants to so in the game after the
rook comes to e4 a lot of stuff going on
in his position Bobby Fischer looks at
it and says although I do have the Queen
and the rook here I want to go and bring
my rook back here to d8 attacking the
Queen here on h8 another thing this does
for Bobby Fischer it's a discovered
attack with this Bishop on this rook
here on e4 so just another strong attack
attacking now both the rook and the
Queen Queen be the most important that
piece for Spassky he decides to go ahead
and bring that here to g7 then the Queen
comes to f5 attacking now two attackers
on this rook on e4 as well as the
Knights here on a g5 now we see the King
come up here to b3 and then Bobby
Fischer plays Queen to d5 I think he had
a stronger attack if he brings his rook
down here to the one trying to get this
roof behind enemy lines he has so many
strong attacks he can have now with this
Queen to d5 if it wants to and there's a
lot more
you know attacks that Bobby Fischer has
limited squares that Spassky can go to
with this rook back here we could see
the rook come to you know e to now and
then after a - maybe Queen to d5 then
after your king - B - well you can see
that the pressure start to build here
and there's none a ways for white to
really defend this very well the Queen
here on a g7 it's not gonna be getting
involved into action near quick enough
and so I think this was a a stronger way
let's go in the game but decided to play
Queen here - d5
King to a3 Queen to d2 so trying to do
it all by himself here on D - with this
Queen this allows the rook to come over
here to b4 and this is gonna be a huge
defender for White Queen to c1 a check
but you can see this rook is just able
to defend since there's only one
attacker here Queen here - a1 rook here
- ay - so just repeating the moves Queen
to c1 rook here - B - and we repeat it
once again and we do have a draw in this
position I have repeated the moves
enough to have a draw so at the end of
the day we do have back-to-back drawls
game 14 and now game 15 Bobby Fischer
still has a three-point advantage so
things are looking bright especially
with the black pieces now Bobby Fischer
will have the white pieces look to
extend his lead but and that door was
the fence that we really haven't seen
before it was the the poison pond now
getting into the main line both sides
really had an opportunity to take it
white was leading for much of the game
they decided to get a little aggressive
with this Queen over on the Kings side
the board really took his queen out of
the equation and Bobby Fischer at the
end of that was able to really find a
strong attack but just wasn't able to
capitalize put all pieces together and
get that into a guinta the other day an
exciting match for a draw but no player
was able to get the final victory but
that is game 15 and the night
seventy-two World Chess Championship
hopefully you guys are enjoying the
series and I will see you guys in the
next video for game number 16